this is the neighborliness russia wants
belarus welcoming russian troops weapons
and the russian defense minister
in ukraine troops prepare for the
opposite purpose
to repel the russian military
just 40 kilometers from the russian
border in kharkiv ukrainians are
remarkably calm but defiant
no no way he'll leave says this man if
he must he will defend his city
ukrainians view their history through
the lens of russian oppression under
stalin and others for many russians the
two countries are bound by culture
language and geography
vladimir putin has called russians and
ukrainians one people this is a myth
that was created to support
russian imperial ambitions they had to
justify their claims to ukrainian
territory for most of the 20th century
ukraine was the western bulwark of the
soviet union 15 republics led by russia
that made up the largest country in
modern history seven warsaw pact nations
in eastern europe provided a further
buffer to the nato countries in the west
but after the soviet union dissolved in
1991 the soviet republics became
independent the former warsaw pact broke
apart those countries and three soviet
states in the baltics have since joined
nato russia is determined not to let
ukraine be next the build-up of the
united states and nato's forces next to
the russian borders is of great concern
russia has always seen nato as an
organization that was formed with one
purpose which was to contain russia in
many ways this is president putin going
back to
um
address the outcome of the cold war to
rewrite the rules of the european
security order
returning russia to its glory days
depends on ukraine and its strategic
access to the black sea and to europe
the takeover of crimea and the incursion
into eastern ukraine in 2014 may have
been a prelude to what's happening now
staging the russian military in belarus
and along ukraine's eastern border prior
to a possible invasion that could even
encircle the capital kiev i believe
putin sees himself in the history books
look at what happened with belarus with
kazakhstan now ukraine is the biggest
chunk and the most important part in
this puzzle
if ukraine is the crucial piece of the
puzzle it's not the only piece other
former soviet states are watching and
worrying like georgia the faith of
ukraine has a lot to actually say about
the fate of other small nations in
eastern europe and particularly in the
vicinity of russia if putin's aim is to
ensure russian security its neighbors
believe they will pay the price to
achieve it eric sorensen global news